[Musique]
alors on veut des révélations veut des
scoop on veut des dos comme on dit sur
le squeeze vous allez [ __ ] les a mais
à chaque fois j'ai l'impression que j'ai
pas d'autres anecdotes à raconter et à
chaque fois on fait les jours passent
les nuits passe les douches passe-passe
cui la douche est un moment qui stimule
la créativité et hop il s'ouvrir au
monde et à chaque fois c'est pas des
trucs qui me met en valeur du tout c'est
génial j'ai été un boulet pendant des
années je suis encore mais je me rendrai
compte que dans 8 9 ans et je vous
racontais des trucs que j'ai fait
maintenant dans 8 9 ans c'est chiant
cette phrase je gagne du temps est-ce
que je profite de cette dernière seconde
vous n'êtes pas au courant de certaines
choses
et voilà elle jouera quand tout commence
quand j'avais 11 ans j'habitais dans la
banlieue parisienne du nom d'anthony un
endroit très ghetto c'est faux
entièrement faux la plupart des gens ont
des maisons les gens vivent très très
bien tout allait bien pour moi puisque
je n'étais pas encore très addict aux
jeux vidéo je jouais de manière
raisonnable puis je sortais m'amuser
avec mes amis des fois j'allais à la
piscine municipale
même si j'avais fait me noyer là je vous
avais raconté styger dans une autre
vidéo c'est pas grave le lui lui
continue de pratiquer ces petites
longueurs à la piscine ça lui fait du
bien et ce sont un petit peu aquaman ce
jour là on était en juin grand soleil
dans le ciel je me dis ça y est c'est
mon jour aujourd'hui je vais nager plus
vite qu'un poisson j'arrive à la piscine
je paie ma petite place je laime changé
là ces moments chien tu mets le bonnet
de bain qui est la pire texture du monde
les mecs il y avait un bonnet de bain en
toile moi j'avais subi en plastique qui
te tuerais que je continue mais le pire
bonnet frère je suis sûr que ça là c'est
à cause de ce bonnet à l'époque il en a
arraché des cheveux mais bon bref je
sors du vestiaire je marche en direction
de la piscine je passe fameux bain
pompiers ignoble dans le cas il ya
toutes les maladies du monde mais qu'à
la tuberculose là dedans comme la
plupart des gens au lieu de marcher
dedans je marche au liban pour le
contourner et en arrivant j'ai une
petite tradition souvent et vous avez à
la piscine municipale ya souvent le
bassin aux dimensions olympiques pour
faire des longueurs et tout un beau
gosse et à le petit bassin c'est pour
les gens un peu enfant où les gens qui
ont un retard mental comme moi et ce
bassin là il a un avantage c'est que
l'eau est plus chaude que dans notre
bassin alors à chaque fois j'avais pour
habitude de faire un petit tour dans ce
petit bassin avant d'aller dans le grand
bain dans le petit bassin et mais tous
les mecs comme moi qui voulais pas
affronter la fraîcheur du grand bassin
et du coup ils étaient tous temps blindé
de monde se bat c'est un mec et là
j'arrive miracle il ya personne les gens
sont autour du bassin mais ne sont pas
dedans je me dis [ __ ] j'ai le petit
bassin pour moi tout seul ça y est c'est
plus beau jour de ma vie je me suis un
petit peu comme bill gates que j avais
mon jacuzzi privé
vous sortez la douille arrivé je tape le
plus beau sprint de ma vie en direction
du bassin jeu
plus beau sens vers le petit bassin j'ai
atterri dans l'eau j'ai l'impression
d'être le roi du monde et quand je
remonte à la surface
les emmerdes commencent il ya un mec
dans l'eau en face de moi qui me
regardent un peu bizarre alors je
comprends pas je me dis merde est ce que
mon saut était tellement style et que je
les fais complexé je sais pas [ __ ] rab
et j'avais de lego déjà à l'époque
et là je vois que dans sa main il a un
instrument bizarre que je serai pas
identifié mais j'ai jamais vu un mec à
la piscine avec sas est née une frite
nir a rebondi un jet ski alors c'est
quoi et parallèlement à ce que j'observe
j'entendais rire tout autour de la
piscine tchicamboud pas mais qu'est ce
que j'ai perdu mon short de bain dans le
feu de l'action et je réalise que ce
qu'il a dans la main c'est un aspirateur
aquatique et qu'il était en train
d'aspirer la merde qu'un enfant avait
fait dix minutes avant que je plonge
dans l'eau c'est beau vous vous doutez
bien étant donné qu'il était vraiment
collé à moi le mec j'avais vraiment
sauté sur la merde
j'étais ravie je sors de l'eau j'ai très
très long cette fois ci en marchant dans
le patient il ya la tuberculose broca ou
nettoyer les les résidus s'il y en a
jamais de kaka sur mes pieds je retourne
aux vestiaires la meuf de l'accueil vois
je retourne aux vestiaires et média sas
mal pas si ça va tout va bien mais c'est
moi je veux devenir invisible à l'heure
actuelle vous comprenez ça je veux plus
personne ne me parle pendant deux
semaines je veux mourir je suis rentré
chez moi humilié ma dignité est resté
dans le bassin tout comme la mère de ce
jeune garçon si toi carrière cette vidéo
soit souvenir d'avoir chier dans le
petit bassin de la piscine municipale de
anthony par votre mère foudre ok j'ai
avec mes coupes manor dix ans après ses
bons voilà à la première révélation est
faite j'ai sauté dans un bassin rempli
de kaka on peut passer à autre chose
c'est bon merci deuxième anecdote ça
s'est passé quand j'étais au lycée en
seconde
j'étais dans un centre commercial qui
s'appelle okabe qui situe au kremlin
bicêtre pareil pas très loin d'ailleurs
de anthony les détails de merde mais il
faut que je gagne du temps sur la vidéo
encore une fois là vous n'êtes pas au
courant de ce qui va suivre donc ma
dignité et encore un peu présent j'avais
des potes qui devait me rejoindre là-bas
et je sais pas pourquoi j'ai une grosse
idées de gags nul à chier mais vraiment
un gag nul vraiment genre le gag du
cafard en plastique à côté c'est énorme
je vais un supermarché qui avait dans un
centre commercial
et je me dis [ __ ] avant que mes potes
arrive je vais acheter une teinture et
je vais me la faire et comme ça quand
ils arriveront j'aurai les cheveux noirs
et ils comprendront pas trop drôle
alors je vais au supermarché je veux
rayon peinture y en a des milliards des
milliards mais que je savais pas qu'il y
avait autant de marques il faisait des
teintures je prends une teinture et je
vois en petit son côté la boîte qu'il ya
marqué attention tu veux acheter une
teinture et on te dis attention
bizarre tester la teinture avant de
l'appliquer sur votre cuir chevelu à
pourvoir si j'aime la couleur écru sûr
de bien vouloir prendre celle ci est pas
une haute ou mettez un peu de produit
sur une toute petite partie de votre
peau pour voir si elle ne réagit pas mal
pendant les 24 prochaines heures
c'est vrai que des gens sont allergiques
aux teintures mais pas moi je me dirige
alors avec matin sur toute neuve dans
les toilettes du centre commercial on en
est là on en est là sur le mec va au
bout de son bail il se dit pas un moment
peut-être que c'est une idée de merde je
mets ma tête sous l'eau en plus le
lavabo était petit donc j'avais genre la
tête coincée entre le robinet et l'évier
c'est un enfer j'applique la teinture je
rince je suis content je sors des
toilettes avec les cheveux noirs mes
potes étaient déjà arrivés le gag marche
très peu ils font vraiment un pas de
plus et a les cheveux noirs on va manger
mais laird la suite est bien plus triste
le soir je me couche et mon crâne me
gratte énormément je me gratte une grade
je me gratte puis je me dis qu'on soit
grade généralement faut pas trop de
gratter ça empire le truc tu vois un peu
comme un bouton de moustiques alors
j'arrête de gratter je dors très mal
très très mal le matin je me lève je me
regarde dans le miroir et la mecque je
fais une découverte exceptionnelle
c'était la taille de mon crâne
avait triplé de volume avec ma tête
c'était une montgolfière mon pote je
ressemblais un alien de marsatac frère
j'ai vu ma mère ma mère a explosé de
rire moi j'étais en pleurs je me disais
mais c'est grave ça se trouve la tête va
vraiment explosé quoi je suis pas allé à
l'hôpital je me suis dit bon on voit ça
va passer c'est une petite allergies
rien de grave [ __ ] y'a pas quelqu'un
autour de moi qui m'a dit peut-être ce
match chez le médecin on sait jamais le
surlendemain je me réveille nouvelles
surprises il y avait l'équivalent de
cette bouteille d'eau en liquide dans
mon front c'est ce qu'on appelle de
l'odem j'avais une poche mecs dans mon
front de vraiment star matelas hall truc
je décide alors d'aller aux urgences
parce que là c'est chaud quoi à monsieur
m'accueille il me dit ah vous a fait une
allergie à une teinture vous je dis oui
il me dit bon je m'appuie sur votre
front pour voir si le thème est vraiment
énorme
en suisse il est vraiment énorme il peut
peut-être se prolonger dans votre coup
et ça va appuyer sur vos voies
respiratoires vous allez mourir oui
baba sy a pu voir sur frau mec mais moi
découvrir dans le fond va si je veux pas
mourir le mec mais sa meilleure force
dans son doigt pour appuyer sur mon
front son doigt s'enfonce dans mon front
on ne voit plus son doigt et un certain
son doigt il me dit bon c'est rien vous
en faites pas allez bonne nuit
mais deux mois un truc pour que ça
dégonfle pour je me sente mise au projet
de complexe et pour ce genre de ma
dépression je sais pas je rentre comme
ça tranquillement sur mon trottoir je
marche en direction de la maison je me
dis tout ça ne sera bientôt qu'un
mauvais souvenir au pire c'est pas grave
ça reste entre moi et ma mère mais
personne du lycée n'était au courant mon
honneur est sauf et sur le trottoir d'en
face un mec leurs gardes il me reconnaît
il explose de rire et continue son
chemin autant vous dire que le lendemain
je n'ai pas passé un bon lot et du tout
pensé wow 4
à partir de ce jour je n'ai plus jamais
oser me teindre les cheveux
oui ses cheveux sont très les amis
maintenant trêve de plaisanterie nous
passons à la dernière anecdote qui est
celle où j'ai le plus de regrets ou j'ai
merdé comme jamais ma mère m'a envoyé
chaque année en colonie elle m'avait
envoyé trois ou quatre années de suite
dans la même colonie qui était une
colonie de cheval savait que j'adorais
les animaux du coup j'étais tout content
jeux et des chevaux j'ai caressé suite
du cheval jetées au vent ça dure entre
une et trois semaines une colonie vous
savez très bien que certains soirs quoi
on fait le mur bah oui on sort en
cachette de la chambre en faisant
attention aurons-nous des animateurs
pour pas qu'ils nous prennent la main
dans le sac qu'on soit puni ce soir là
c'était le dernier soir de la colonie et
on avait décidé avec mes potes d'aller
dans le dortoir des filles
le problème c'est que dans ce centre
équestre le dortoir des filles se
trouvaient à l'opposé du dortoir des
hommes
on avait un pote qui est en creux sur
une fille mais ça je le savais pas alors
et c'était le dernier soir il n'avait
pas osé franchir le pas et il était trop
deg et nous en tant que bons potes on
lui a dit mec ce soit on va atteindre le
dortoir des filles et tu vas dormir avec
no et noémie et dans la meuf sûr qu'il
avait un creux jamais entendu blais
compris alors on sort de la chambre un
modérateur passe devant nous il ne nous
voit pas on traverse le couloir ont fini
par sortir du bâtiment et là on se
retrouve en extérieur le problème c'est
qu'à l'extérieur se trouvait sur
quasiment tous les murs des spots
automatique qui avait une zone de
détection très très large si un spot
s'allume ça veut dire que quelqu'un est
passé devant c'est à dire que les
animateurs vont venir vers le spot est
fouillé dans les environs et se passer
le mot en gros on est mort c'est un spot
se détecte ok vous comprenez ça alors on
s'avance discrètement de bus sont
enduits son chien spot on ne peut pas à
passer devant parce que sinon on passe
devant le bureau de la direction
d'enquêté avait des animateurs qui
devait leur café leur clope la rai
buvait pas des clopes et les fumées mais
romain compris du coup on est obligé de
faire un détour est de passer par
l'intérieur de l'enclos des chevaux en
pleine nuit alors on passe dans cet
enclos pour esquiver le bot mon pote
marges dans une merde on se retient de
rire parce que vous savez c'est horrible
situation où on a envie d'exploser de
rire mais tu sais que c'est explose de
rire tu es mort mais du coup tu es
encore plus envie d'exploser de rire
dans le couloir qui mène pour trottoirs
des filles non oui on arrive nouvel
apport du dortoir
on rentre l'une des filles dit [ __ ] ça
plus d'un coup quelqu'un 1 pt non non
c'est juste nous kiev traverser les
enclos des chevaux et là arnaud mon ami
va dans le lit de noémie je sais pas ce
qui me prend je vais dans le lit de
noélie avec lui pourquoi mais moi
j'étais innocent j'avais 11 ans moi
j'avais pas de penser un peu perverse ou
je sais pas quoi pour moi les hommes et
les femmes ne faisais pas l'amour qui
pouvaient cohabiter en toute liberté
sans jamais avoir d attirance les uns
pour les autres le sexe ça n'existait
pas là vous vous dites bon et abuse mais
perd ça les a pas empêchés de discuter
de s'embrasser se met s'embrasser à mais
non attendez je me glisse entre arnaud
et nous évite de manière à vraiment
[ __ ] toutes les chances d'arnaud
d'avoir un quelconque contact physique
avec noemi avec une ligne on parle on
parle
arnaud des fois il arrive à 5 6 dans la
combine et on parle avec nos millions
par les arts wd petit coup de coude un
peu comme ça de plus en plus fort au
début les j'ai mes dates du coup un peu
mieux comme ça je comprends pas pourquoi
il fait ça et je lui dis mais arnaud
pourquoi tu me les coups de coude le
pire ami possible du coup noémie elle
comprend regard dont il a envie de
s'approcher d'elle et qui c'est pour ça
qu'il met des coups de coude noémie à
langueux la renommée arnaud pourquoi tu
mets des coups de coude à l'uqat est
malade je fini par sortir du lit il
passe trois minutes dans l'eau avant de
se faire exclure du lit par noémie qui
était trop fatiguée parce qu'on a parlé
pendant une heure et demie et la
renommée passe un savon je croyais qu'on
était potes ce que tu as fait c'est
abusé à cause de toi j'ai pas pu
l'embrasser et je la reverrai plus après
deux jours et ça je trouve mais qui
s'était marié aujourd'hui si j'avais pas
fait ça ça se trouve c'était le début
d'une grande histoire
arnaud vraiment désolé d'avoir nique et
honfleur j'espère qu'aujourd'hui tu
pense plus à elle que c'est de
l'histoire ancienne et vraiment je
m'excuse j'aurais dû comprendre ce qui
se passait entre toi elle sentir cette
petite électricité et vous laisser les
amis c'est la fin de cette vidéo
j'espère qu'elle vous a plu et que vous
ne m'en voulez pas je sais qu'il ya tous
les mecs qui ont vu la vidéo on le somme
contre moi on n'a pas envie que ça nous
arrive à nous ce que j'ai fait arnaud
j'étais jeune innocente je me rendais
pas compte de ce que je faisais vraiment
mais je m'en veux si vous saviez comme
je m'en suis voulu qu alice dona après
quand j'ai compris ce que j'avais fait à
cet homme mais c'était pas mais la vue
du ciel vous a plu j'espère vous aimerez
quand même
mais vidéo après avoir appris que j'ai
sauté dans une piscine remplie de cacau
que j'ai une tête mon bol fier ou que
j'ai empêché un pote de pécho écoutez
moi je vis plutôt bien malgré toutes ces
erreurs c'est un peu trop d'impact je me
porte bien
bon voilà n'hésitez pas à me dire
d'aller grand test vous avait gaffé avec
un pote qui avait un crush sur une meuf
ça peut être drôle c'est trop drôle ces
histoires là c'est horrible et c'est
très drôle à la fois vous fais plein de
bisous j'espère que ça vous a plu
j'ai encore deux autres anecdotes pour
une future vidéo anecdotes décidément je
n'arrête pas d'en avoir
bon c'est incroyable et jeudi avant une
prochaine vidéo portez vous bien au
revoir
[Musique]
là
thiriez chevallier